you
[Music]
so I'm going to talk about optimality
and a little bit about intuition and
creativity with in respect to AI which
are sort of three topics that I've been
thinking about a lot over the last year
but before I started to want to put up
this diagram mostly for the benefit of
yam and yeah so you know we a deep mind
we we think reinforcement learning is
you know really great and general sort
of way to think about intelligence you
know in this sort of very high-level
sense of an agent that builds a model of
the world around it based on its
experiences and observations including
any rewards it gets and then it uses
that model to imagine the future and
plant make planned an action sequence
plans about how to get towards whatever
goal that might have in mind and I think
you know within that if we can solve all
the problems within that we'll we'll
have solved intelligence and indeed it
is the way that natural intelligence
works now of course there's obviously
lots of issues with credit assignment
and data efficiency and many many issues
that are known about reinforcement
learning but we're working on and many
other people working on many solutions
to those problems including imitation
learning hierarchical planning and so on
transfer learning that can get around
some of these data efficiency issues but
with that there's lots of things I'd
like to talk about by only got twenty
minutes so I'm actually going to focus
most of this talk on alphago and what's
happened in the last year but even
actually as recently as the last couple
of weeks and the kinds of general things
that we've taken from that in terms of
progress towards AI so you can think of
this as a proxy if you like for the
progress we've made over the last year
or two
towards AGI so alphago hopefully most of
you know now how to play go by now with
with alphago out there but for those of
you don't this is a go board go is
played on a 1919 board it starts off
totally empty black and white take turns
to put stones on the board they can put
them anywhere on the board but once
they're placed they stay there so they
don't move on the board now the aim of
the game is very simple is to surround
empty spaces of territory also surround
your opponent's stones to capture them
and the player that surrounds the most
amount of terror
three wins the game now go itself is
originated in China 3000 years ago it's
more popular than ever now today's 40
million players across Asia and their
2,000 professionals who make their
living just off of go and spent their
entire lives and study and go and in
fact they've been professionals and go
for many hundreds of years now and in
terms of the complexity of the game I
think it's the most elegant game that
mankind has ever devised so there are
the only two rules if I had an extra
five minutes I could teach you those
rules but those two rules ended up
creating an immense amount of complexity
and one way to think about that is there
are 10 to the power 170 possible
position bingo
possible board positions which is more
than the atoms in the observable
universe so you can't brute force sort
of solve go which is why one of the
reasons why it's been so hard for
computers to play so if we compare this
to chess obviously its closest neighbor
in go the branching factor of 200 there
are 200 possible moves in an average
positioning go whereas in chess is about
20 so it's an order of magnitude higher
branching factor but they actually the
more difficult problem is how to write
an evaluation function that will tell
the system who is winning in a
particular position whether it's black
or white and it's very difficult and all
sought to be impossible for many years
to create this kind of valuation
function so let's take a look at why
that's hard well I think it actually is
impossible to probably create a
handcrafted set of logical rules to set
tell the system who's winning and that's
how chess evaluation functions generally
work chess can put chess computers so
they distill a bunch of knowledge from
human grandmasters and they codify that
up in databases of rules and and those
end up giving an equation which the
system can nu to determine whether
positions good or not and the reason
that so Harding goes for is multiple
reasons so one is that there's no
concept of materiality and go
so in chess you know fed the first
approximation you can just add up the
pieces on each side of the board you
know queen is nine points rook is five
points and so on and
has got more points is generally winning
and go all the pieces are worth the same
also goes a constructive game and in
this sense chess is a destructive game
and what I mean by that is in chess all
the pieces start on the board and they
get removed as the game goes on so the
game gets simplified as the game goes on
and go it's a contrast constructive game
so the board starts empty and you put
pieces on the board so that means if
you're trying to make a value 8a mid
game position a complex game position
you don't have all the information isn't
just on the ball you also have to make a
prediction into the future about what
might happen whereas with a chess
position in the mid game you have all
the information there that you need to
make that evaluation also a very small
change to even like one stone by one
position 1 square and can totally change
the evaluation of the position so it's
it's very brittle 2 changes and because
of all this the way humans get round
playing mister very high level is they
generally use their intuition rather
than calculating abilities like you
wooden chess so if you ask a great go
player why they've made particular move
in a very complex game they'll often
tell you it felt right they'll use those
words where the chess grandmaster will
never really say that they'll tell you
you know I thought a was going to happen
then I was going to plan B and then I
thought C would happen now that plan may
not turn out to be very good but they'll
usually have an explicit plan in mind
we'd go it's much more implicit so what
we did to get around both of these
problems is turn to the neural networks
and in fact we trained to neural
networks to get around both of these two
challenges so we created a policy
network that basically learnt a
probability distribution over moves
watch moves were more likely to be to be
valuable to assess and this was
initially bootstrap from human data
actually amateur games from an online go
server and then improve through
reinforcement learning so the program
played against itself and improved those
predictions until it could beat the the
human trained version of the policy net
the second networker we created with a
value network which took all of these
games self play games that alphago
played against different versions of
itself and
created a huge database of millions of
positions where you had the position as
the input we also knew the final result
of the game and that allowed us to
create this fabled evaluation Network we
call it the value net which could give
you a probability of who is going to win
from that position based on the
configuration of the pieces so the input
would be the board and the output would
be a value between 0 & 1 a real number
between 0 & 1
- telling you where the white or black
was winning with 0.5 there's meaning an
even position and we combine this
together with with Monte Carlo tree
search to create alphago I haven't got
time to go into the technical details of
this but if you're interested you can
you can check out their nature paper and
alphago which has actually came out in
February of this year actually February
March of this year and since then
Chinese company Tencent have created an
alphago Klout clone which is now very
powerful and also Japanese project and
this has also created a program called
deep Zen so they've used these
techniques to create their own dough
programs now as many of you know we took
this program forward to alphago for our
ultimate challenge was to take on Lisa
doll who's a sort of legend of the game
acknowledged as the greatest player of
the past decade and has 18 world titles
and surprisingly we won the match in
Seoul for one and it was sort of
acclaimed by many of the experts in this
field in both bingo and in and in AI
computer go that it was about a decade
before people were expecting this
breakthrough to happen now it wasn't it
was important obviously that we won the
match but actually what was more
interesting was how alphago played and
the kinds of moves that it came up with
so I'm going to quickly show you one
special position from game 2 which is
probably the most famous thing that
alphago has done and this was the
petitioning game - and alphago here is
black and it's on move 37 so it's
relatively early in the game and Lisa
Dahl is playing the white stones and
alphago played this move here on the
right hope you can see that at the back
there which is called a shoulder hit
move right next to the white stone here
and this is considered to be an
incredible move and totally unthinkable
for professionals to do and I'll just
quite and briefly explain why this move
was so astounding to the NGO world so
there are two important lines in go
there's the third line which is marked
here now if you play a stone on the
third line what you're saying to your
opponent is that you're interested in
taking territory surrounding empty space
to the side of the board
so obviously if you play on the third
line they're trying to take territory
instead of that if you play on the
fourth line what you're saying to your
opponent is you can have some territory
on the side of the board but I want
power and influence towards the center
of the board inwards looking and the
idea of playing on the fourth line is
that later on in the game you can use
that power and influence to create give
you points somewhere else on the board
much much later in the game now the
perceived wisdom of 3,000 years of
playing go is that playing on the third
and fourth lines is about equally
balanced so you know the trade-off you
get from the influence from playing on
the fourth line from giving your
territory away to your ponal and third
line is about equal so that's why this
move is so astounding because alphago
here is telling Lisa dolls well in fact
it's signaling that it's worth taking
influence to the center of the board
from the fifth line so one line further
in giving away territory from the fourth
line so that much more territory so
that's considered to be very suboptimal
in go and hence this move is incredibly
surprising for any kind of go
professional to it to eat and and they
wouldn't even consider living somewhere
like that
so it turns out that this move ended up
being key to alphago winning the game
and the reason that happened is around
15 moves later these two stones I've
marked here in the bottom left of the
board the fighting from the left hand
corner ended up spilling out into the
sense of the board and ultimately these
black stones connected with this move 37
stone on the right around 50 60 moves
later so and that's what ultimately that
motif is what won the game so
interestingly and go unlike you know
goes considered to be a sort of art form
in Asia more kin to poetry or something
like that than it is to just a game and
but interesting thing about go is sort
of like objective
in the sense that move you know anyone
of us here could come up with a random
move that would be new or novel but the
question is is it any good and in go of
course we can put this to the test so
this move 37 has gone down in history
not because it's novel but also because
it was critical to the win here so
there's some new idea here that's worth
studying
now obviously Lisa Dahl came back in
Game four
and he won his match in Game four which
he said was the most valuable win of his
career with his own incredible inventive
move on lose 78 and I won't haven't got
time to go into why this move was
amazing but it was interesting that he
you know his creative qualities were
able to come up with something like this
that fooled that version of alphago so I
only want to mention a little bit about
intuition and creativity this whole game
is about intuition and creativity that's
the way humans play it so you know has
alphago sort of displayed these
attributes well I think to talk about
that we need to sort of give some
definitions to these two terms that I've
used so you know one I think we're all
about intuition one way of operationally
sort of defining it is that it's sort of
implicit knowledge that's acquired
through experience that it's not
consciously expressible or even
accessible so we can't access that
knowledge consciously ourselves and
certainly not in a way that we can
express to others so you might ask well
how do we know that knowledge exists and
the quality of that knowledge will
obviously we can verify this
behaviorally by testing it and then go
that's very easy by testing what the
system would do in a particular position
so what about creativity
well one operational definition of
creativity and I'm not saying this
bubble any means this covers all of
creativity is the ability to synthesize
knowledge you already have in all such a
way to produce a novel original idea in
the service of some goal and I think at
least by these two definitions of
intuition and creativity I think alphago
has clearly demonstrated these abilities
albeit in a constrained domain like go
so the impact of the game was pretty
huge 280 million people watched the
match across Asia and it would cause a
huge sort of storm in the NGO world so
actually just over the new year
miss brake we unleashed our new version
of alphago on the internet and on the
online goat servers the two most popular
ones in Asia and actually alphago won
its match to 60 nil against all the
world pop players so actually all the
top 20 players in the world played
against it in the end and including we'd
be the world number one two J's three
nil so all right so it does seem like we
fixed those those malice gap issues and
what was really interesting is that so
these games were massively reported
across Asia and you know thousands of
people watching the online games even
though we didn't we didn't officially
announce them as alphago matches until
after the matches we wanted a clean test
on these but there were these 60 games
are now become a treasure trove for the
go playing world and after those come up
with many innovations that now the
professionals are analyzing with and
combing over and thinking about
incorporating into their own games so
here's two here
so here's alphago is in both cases black
and here in one position against her
again against a number 20 player in the
world
alphago plays in the bottom right hand
corner here on a course called the three
three point and this is considered if
you are novice and you played this your
teacher of basically slap your hand
because this corner is way too small
considered to be way too small to play
this early in the game and yet alphago
has shown that this is a plausible
strategy here's another example on the
right hand side think against the number
10 in the world where an alphago has
cooled what's called crawling along the
second line now that's considered to be
also a complete unthinkable thing to do
because you're getting so little
territory for your moves you're just
getting one line of territory on the
side of the board and yet alphago here
shows that this can be a very extremely
strong strategy in certain conditions so
so these things are completely
overturning 3,000 years of received
wisdoms are the sort of ancient Chinese
proverbs if you like they're being
handed down through generations
so ghuli so units have take my word for
it this is what some of the top players
in the world said about alphago after
they played these matches over
the Christmas break so really is a
legend in China he's one of the most
World titles of anyone in the world and
he said afterwards together humans in AI
will soon uncover the deeper mysteries
of go Kuji the world number one the
current world number one he said after
the matches humanity has played go for
thousands of years and yet as AI has
shown us we have not yet even scratched
the surface the union of human computer
players will usher in a new era together
man and AI can find out the truth of go
so this is really for them this is hard
for us to understand in the West but for
them this is kind of very profound
exploration for them it's a bit like the
way we would explore science so I think
this is kind of an interesting paradigm
for us to think about AGI in general in
more topics as we improve AI techniques
and they become more general you know
the idea of humans and machines
collaborating together cooperatively I
think will achieve amazing things and I
think of AI is sort of and human
ingenuity augmented by AI tools as
unlocking our true potential so I think
of alphago as for the go players at
least a bit like the Hubble telescope is
for astrophysicists you know kind of
ultimate tool for them to explore their
particular universe in this case the
game would go so that made me think
about optimality and discovering
optimality and and and sort of you know
these ideas of thinking how far off
optimal are we and in go this is a this
is a natural topic of conversation they
talk about is how many handicap stones
how many Head Start stones would they
need in order to beat to be able to
compete against God or perfect play and
the assumption was that the top players
were around two stones away from perfect
place so that wins if they got two stone
hand headstart they would be able to
play be a perfect player and it what
we've shown is that after three thousand
years of study this is not nearly
sufficient enough to find optimal play
and we're actually a long way away from
that but interesting thing is that
unlike chess programs I think alphago is
going to help humans get better at go
because in this happening Jeff obviously
20 years ago with deep blue and a sort
of for the following programs but chess
programs are generally better than human
players because they're better
tactically they don't make any mistakes
and they have huge databases of both
openings and end games that are solved
so for example in end games I think the
latest is any nine piece or less
position is now being solved offline by
a huge brute force so obviously no human
player you can tell a human player you
know make less mistakes that doesn't
help them or you can say to them you
know in this eighth game position eight
piece position we know that Y it is
winning but that also doesn't help you
you know they can't memorize millions of
200 move sequences so we're but alphago
is better strategically and I think it's
what is actually we shown in these sort
of games we played is that these are
quality of new ideas qualitative new
ideas that players can potentially
absorb and use in their own games and
this has already been happening so I
think the strength of human play is
going to see huge improvement as we
release more and more games of alphago
and eventually maybe the program itself
so I think what's happened here is that
we've allowed we shown human players
that are actually stuck in a local
Maxima and we've shown them that it can
be broken out of and maybe this is going
to usher in a new era of go many people
are talking about this as in history
there of go there's been two big giant
leaps of progress one several hundreds
of years ago with more modern go
techniques and then one again in
nineteen thirties with this legendary
player called Gosai again who was in his
prime in the 30s and 40s and it's been
thought that human players improved by
two stones during those that period when
go side game introduced all these new
ideas and people are talking about this
alphago era as maybe a new era and go
like that
so alphago's enabled these fascinating
mystery to be explored but there are
countless other domains that also suffer
from this kind of combinatorial
explosion obviously we're not doing this
just to play go we want to use these
general techniques to to use in other
areas and we think of AGI as the
ultimate tool for us to investigate and
explore the universe around us and I
think you know here there are many many
areas of science I think we can apply
this to and you know here are two
examples I think that would be
particularly I think amenable to this
sort of approach material design like
superconductor design and perhaps drug
discovery I think might be two areas
where
we can apply these kinds of technique
and we're already applying it in areas
of healthcare we're looking at robotics
and also just earlier this year last
year looking at optimizing data centers
too so we used variations of the alphago
algorithms to optimize the google data
centers and the power they used and we
say 15% of the power using these data
centers and we're now rolling out out
across the fleet so what are these four
outstanding challenges so we've made a
lot of progress has been huge excitement
over the last five years but there's
plenty of challenges yet to have been
solved that we're going to need if we
want to get anywhere close to AGI so
here's just a list of ones that we are
working very hard on imagination based
planning with generative models
hierarchical planning unsupervised
learning with we've heard about memory
and one-shot learning so sort of having
episodic memory which is our subject to
our recent Masek nature paper learning
abstract concepts continuing transfer
learning and we think these things are
all key topics and we're working very
hard on these and hopefully we'll have
some work to announce on this in the
next year or so so in terms of solutions
and AI I think everyone in this room
probably agrees with these these
sentiments you know we're confronted at
the moment with huge information
overload and system complexity on on the
sort of domains that we would like to to
master whether that's climate or disease
or macroeconomics and you know I think
these are huge challenges for humans to
tackle unaided even the world's top
human experts so I think solving AI is
potentially a meta solution to many of
these other problems and that's why we
work so hard on AI at the mind but
obviously you know the caveat and while
again why we're all here is that all
these sort of powerful new technologies
and AI is certainly no different must be
used ethically responsibly for the
benefit of all and that's why you know
we've been helping with efforts like the
partnership on AI and I know there's
many other people in room we've worked
hard on that as a first sort of baby
step towards coordinating ethical use of
this kind of technology and the dream
certainly for me and many a deep mine is
to use this kind of AI that we're
talking about to
ái scientists or a I assisted science
and to make sort of a I assisted science
and medicine possible accessing
[Applause]
[Music]